[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ السوري ياسر حسين في مدينه
دمشق والتحق منذ الطفوله بمساجدها لحفظ
القران الكريم على يد كبار المحافظين في
بلاد الشام قبل التحاقه بالمعهد الشرعي
حيث اتم حفظ القران الكريم كاملا قبل
توليه الامامه والتدريس بعدد من المدارس
القرانيه والمساجد في مسيره لم يتوقف فيها
ترحاله
طبعا القران الكريم من البدايه كان من
الصغر
يعني من عمر سبع سنوات ثمان سنوات ما
نسميه في بلادنا العربيه الكتاب
لكن كنا نحفظ
جزء جزئين ثلاثه وكانت مداومتنا على
الكتاب في العطله الصيفيه في المدارس
الى ان تقريبا لل 16 17 سنه
لما دخلنا الشرعيه ما تسمى المعهد الشرعي
التزمت مع
شيخ القراء
الشيخ عبد الرزاق الحلبي رحمه الله عليه
التزمت معه في حفظ القران الكريم
فكانت الفتره متقطعه اولا يعني بدات
تقريبا بفتره كم شهر بدك تقول ثم انقطعت
عن الحفظ لاسباب الدراسه وكذا
وسبحان الله الشيطان يبدا يبدا
يسول للانسان خاصه بحفظ القران الكريم ان
لا يتابع وفعلا سوى لنا ان الشيطان ذلك
وهذا ديننا اكثر الناس الذين يبداون في
حفظ القران الكريم الى ان رجعت بعدها
بحوالي اشهر سته الى سبعه اشهر الى الشيخ
وتابعت معه الى ان انتهيت تقريبا كان عمري
بال19 سنه تقريبا
ثم بدات مراجعه القران الكريم مع الشيخ
كريم راجح
وعدد من المشايخ طبعا بدون الاجازه
انما مراجعه مع الشيخ فلان والشيخ فلان
شيخ كريم وغيرهم
لتمكين القران الكريم طبعا كانت كان حفظي
القران الكريم على روايه حفص
ما جمعت القراءات انا اجواء القران الكريم
كنا
نحفظ حلقات
وحلقه اللي كنت انا ملتزم فيها مع الشيخ
هي حلقه ما بعد صلاه الفجر كنت انا اسكن
في منطقه في دمشق اسمها مشروع دمر
نصلي الفجر انا واحد اخواني
في مسجدي ابو في في المسجد اللي التزمت
فيه ثم نذهب من مشروع دمر الى المسجد
الاموي الذي هو مديره شيخ القراء تقريبا
نركب حافله ثم ننزل في منطقه اخرى ثم نركب
حافله اخرى ثم نسير على الاقدام ما يقارب
تقريبا نصف ساعه او اكثر حتى نصل الى
المسجد الاموي حتى نسمع صفحه من القران
الكريم وهذا كل يوم
هذا كل يوم بهذه الطريقه ان كان ثلج ولا
كان حر ولا كان غيره كنا ملتزمين بالحلقه
اليوميه وكانت هذه الحلقه طبعا تضم
ليس اعمار يعني متساويه انما اعمار
متفاوته كان المسن فيها والشباب والصغار
والكبار فيها وكن كانوا منهم من يحفظ
القران الكريم وجاء ليجمع القراءات عند
الشيخ وكان منهم المبتدا وكان منهم من
انتهى من حفظ نصف القران الكريم وغيرها
فكانت اجواء رائعه فعلا بهذا الجهد العظيم
اللي كلما تذكرناه سبحان الله العظيم يعني
نتذكر انه كيف كنا نخرج من الصباح الباكر
من الصباح الباكر حتى نصل الى المسجد بني
اميه حتى نسمع صفحه من القران الكريم يعني
جهد عظيم جدا كنا نتاثر بمشايخ الحرم كثير
الشيخ محمد ايوب وغيره
ومن المشايخ المعروفين اللي كنا فعلا
نحاول تقليد هؤلاء العمالقه منهم الشيخ
عبد الباسط عبد الصمد
وغيرهم من الاشياخ كانت اول مره اذكرها
كنت استلمت مسجد البراء بن عازب في منطقه
من ضواحي الشام
فكانت تجربه يعني
فريده من نوعها انه انا اول مره ام الناس
وما اممت الناس رمضان كله انما كان الامام
يقدمني الى مثلا ركعتين الى اربع ركعات في
الصلاه فكانت تجربه فريده لا انساها ابدا
الى ان بعد ذلك استلمت مسجد
العادل في منطقه مشروع دمر وبعدها انتقلت
الى نفس المنطقه في مسجد الكبير يسمى مسجد
التقوى فكنا طبعا هذا اغلب مساجد الشام
انها نصلي عشرين ركعه التراويح فنختم
القران في رمضان
ساقرا الان من سوره الذاريات جزء من سوره
الذاريات ان شاء الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان المتقين في
جنات وعي
يقول اخذين ما اتاهم ربهم انهم كانوا قبل
ذلك محسنين
كانوا قليلا من الليل ما يهجعون
وبالاسحار هم يستغفرون
وفي اموالهم حق
للسائل والمحروم
وفي الارض ايات للموقنين
وفي
انفسكم افلا تبصرون
وفي السماء رزقكم وما توعدون فورب السماء
والارض انه لحق مثل ما انكم
تنطقون
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حتى القارئ ياسر حسين عساطر حاله هذه
المره في البرازيل كامامام وخطيب في مسجد
الحمزه في ساو باولو اضافه الى توليه
رئاسه القسم الديني بالمدرسه الاسلاميه
البرازيليه التي يامها المئات من ابناء
الجاليه العربيه المسلمه المهاجره التي
استقرت في البرازيل
انتقلت الى البرازيل
باواخر الخمسه وتسعين 1995
وصلت الى البرازيل فاستلمت مسجد صومي
لمده تسع سنوات
ففوجئت ان في البرازيل
الائمه لا يختمون القران في رمضان
وانا اردت ان اطبق تجربتي في سوريا في
البرازيل فكانت تجربه عكسيه علينا ان
الناس ما اعتادت على هذا النمط
خاصه في اول رمضان يعني كثير من الناس ما
احبوا ان الاطاله في الصلاه لانه هنا في
البرازيل يصلون نصلي ثمان ركعات التراويح
مره طبعا فتره
فاستلمت مدير
معهد تحفيظ القران الكريم في منطقه سمبر
ناردو كامبو
وجلبنا الطلبه من كافه انحاء البرازيل
لحفظ القران الكريم وتعليم العربيه طبعا
كان المعهد
داخلي فيه المنامه طبعا والطعام والشراب
وينفق عليه للطالب من من تعليمه للقران
الكريم حتى في في الفتره الصباحيه عندما
يذهب الى المدرسه البرازيليه
وفعلا تخرج من
المعهد طلبه منهم من يحفظ جزء من القران
ومنهم من يحفظ القران كله
وكانت تجربه فريده من نوعها الحمد لله لكن
الان اغلق المعهد ولكن فتحت اليوم مدارس
كثيره لله الحمد في البرازيل لحفظ القران
الكريم طبعا الجاليه الاسلاميه في
البرازيل تاريخها عريق بل تاريخها قديم
جدا من عام 1800 ونيف تقريبا بدات الهجره
الى البرازيل من الدول العربيه
الشرق الاوسط منها لبنان وسوريا وفلسطين
وغيرها من الدول واكثر الدول التي هاجرت
الى البرازيل والى امريكا اللاتينيه وخاصه
البرازيل هي من لبنان فالعدد الاكبر اليوم
في في البرازيل من الجاليات هي الجاليه
اللبنانيه التي فاق عددها 14 مليون
في البرازيل ثم تاتي بعد ذلك طبعا الجاليه
الفلسطينيه وبقيت الجنسيات الاخرى
طبعا
الجاليه بدي اقول استيقظت او فاقت من
سباتها بالستينات
حتى بنت طبعا المراكز منها مركز
المركز الاسلامي جامع البرازيل
والمدرسه الاسلاميه والمقبره الاسلاميه
والى غير ذلك وهذا الشيء هذا هذه الصرح ان
كان المدرسه او المقبره او او المسجد
البرازيل يعني قام على على
المسمى بالبرازيل المسكاتيه هو بايعين
المتجولين
الجاليه اليوم كما قلت انفا يعني
تريد ان تعلم ابنائها القران الكريم
واللغه العربيه باي وسيله كانت منهم من
فكر ان يرسل ولده الى لبنان
او الى الدوله العربيه التي هو منها كان
سوريا ولا لبنان ولا فلسطين ولا غيرها
وطبعا هاي التجربه ما اعطت برايي ما اعطت
النتيجه
التي يفكرون بها النتائج اللي اعطت فعلا
ثمارها عندما التزم ابناء الجاليه
بالمدارس الاسلاميه مدارس تحفيظ القران
الكريم في هذا البلد
ففتحت مدارس في كثير من المساجد في كثير
من المراكز وكثير من الداعمين من من
اهل الخير فتحوا مدارس في هذا البلد
لتحفيظ ابناء الجاليه والحمد لله اليوم
يعني كما ذكرت انفا عندنا كثير من الطلاب
الملتزمين
التزام يومي ليس في العطله الصيفيه او
عطله السبت عطله السبت الالتزام اليومي في
حفظ القران الكريم وتعليم اللغه العربيه
طبعا هو هي البرازيل بلد مسالم اولا بلد
مفتوح للجميع
بلد الحريات
يعني انت اليوم تفتح مؤسسه او تفتح مركز
اسلامي او كذا بالعكس البرازيل تدعم هذا
العمل ان كان مدارس دينيه او مدارس عامه
اخرى فالشعب البرازيلي شعب طيب سعد يحب او
ما يقال
يستقبل الغريب
ويحتضن فعلا ما عنده هذيك العنصريه
البرازيليين ما عندهم تلك العنصريه التي
نسمعها في بعض الدول بالعكس عندهم الحب
للجاليات وما شعرنا في يوم من الايام الا
انا برازيليين
فعلا في هذا البلد الا اننا برازيليين حتى
عندنا هنا في المدرسه الاسلاميه عندنا
طبعا معلمين برازيليين برازيليين وعندنا
معلمين عرب فما في تفرقه بيننا ابدا ابدا
ما نحس الا نشعر الانا نحن شيء واحد
يعني البرازيلي عندما يسمع فعلا القران
الكريم يسر جدا انا اذكر
حدثت معي مره قرات القران امام شخص
برازيلي
فقلت له ماذا شعرت قال ارتعد قلبي شعرت
بشيء غريب
وهو لا يعرف معنى الكلام الذي
يعني اقراه وقال انه والله انا شعرت بشيء
غريب فعلا منذ ان سمعت هذا الكلام في
البرازيليين بالعكس يعني حتى نحن عندما
نقدم القران الكريم هدايا للبرازيليين
يستقبلوا بكل رحابه صدر وبعضهم يسال ما
معنى هذه الكلمه ما معنى هذه الصوره الى
اخره
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
ان للمتقين مفازا
حدائق واعنابا
وكواعب اترابا
وكاسا دهاقا لا يسمعون فيها لغوا ولا
كذابا جزاء
من ربك
عطاء حسابا رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما
الرحمن لا يملكون منه خطابا يوم يقوم
الروح
والملائكه صفا لا يتكلمون
لا يتكلمون الا من اذن له الرحمن وقال
صوابا ذلك اليوم الحق فمن
شاء اتخذ الى ربه مابا
انا
انذرناكم عذابا قريبا
يوم ينظر المرء ما قدمت يدا
ويقول الكافر يا ليتني
كنت ترابا
صدق الله العظيم
حقيقه شهر رمضان في البرازيل اجوائه يعني
ممكن ان تقارنها باجواء الدول العربيه او
يمكن افضل شوي
[موسيقى]
تقام في رمضان مواعد الافطار في اغلب
المساجد طبعا مجانا
باغلب المساجد تقام موائد الافطار ويدعى
اليها ابناء الجاليه
والعائلات
لحضور الافطار في رمضان طبعا ايضا غير
موائد الافطار طبعا تقام حلقات القران في
المساجد الدروس والندوات ايضا في المساجد
مسابقات القران الكريم في المساجد ايضا
مسابقات دينيه ايضا تقام في رمضان يعني جو
حافل
بالبرامج الدينيه
في هذا الشهر العظيم اضافه بعد بعد انتهاء
الشهر طبعا العيد العيد في سان باولو وفي
بعض المدن الكبيره التي تضم عدد كبير من
الجاليه يكون فيها برامج رائعه في رمضان
ان تحضر الجاليه في عدد من المراك التي
تحدد الجاليه ممكن في مزارع بمزرعه او
غيرها وتضم الجاليه تضم يضم المكان الاف
من ابناء الاف من ابناء الجاليه يحضرون
هذا اليوم معايدات في هذا اليوم من الصباح
الى المساء طعام ولعب وشراب وغير ذلك
وبرامج دينيه ايضا وصلوات في ذلك المكان
فيعني هذه الاجواء اتوقع خاصه يوم العيد
مثلا لا نجدها في دوران العربيه
هذا البرنامج الذي نراه في البرازيل
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
ان الذين سبقت لهم
منا الحسنى
اولئك عنها مبعدون
لا يسمعون حسيسها وهم فيما اشتهت
انفسهم خالدون
لا يحزنون الفزع الاكبر وتتلقى هم
الملائكه
وتتلقاهم
الملائكه هذا يومكم الذي
كنتم توعدون
يوم نطوي السماء كطي السجل للكتب كما
بدانا اول خلق نعيد وعدا علينا
انا كنا فاعلين
ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من بعد الذكر ان
الارض يرثها عبادي الصالحون
ان في هذا
لبلاغا لقوم عابدين
وما ارسلناك الا رحمه
للعالمين
بارك الله فيكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات